troisième story on y va crescendo d'âge
et
c'est william leymergie et sophie davant
et bien c'est l'amour fou et c'est beau
de temps en temps là j'ai pas de vidéo
mais ils ont fait la une de closer
regardez là une de closer c'est nous on
n'a pas préparé au mieux d'une
odeur on les voit tous les deux c'est
l'amour fou milliard de bases ou pas il
ya maintenant ils viennent la main il y
aurait là une fois de plus soit là on
fait parler les photos oui à tout le
moins opaque et 2 oui oui ben tu vois ce
puits avant m
internet vous allez voir la photo est
maman d'un papa papa moi vous raconter
l'histoire parce que a on a le temps
c'est là une de closer je peux peut-être
en parler nous réassorti l'histoire en
octobre dernier ça faisait plusieurs
mois qu'on était en fait vous sortez
toujours les choses si l'on a prévu
de nombreuses fois pour la saison
prochaine et sorte que ford se mettant
est mort
en fait ils sont très amis qui m'aident
à 30 ans c'est vraiment des âmes s'ils
retravaillent air sur le plan année ils
ont travaillé ensemble sauf que william
leymergie étaient en couple depuis
depuis toujours et sa femme
malheureusement assez ses parents il ya
deux ans williams et sophie se sont
rapprochés à ce moment là je ne peux pas
dire officiellement née ils sont
amoureux je peux pas le dire mais c'est
une espèce d'amitié exceptionnel
peut-être et non des rapports qui
dépasse le cadre est vraiment un métier
nous regarde pas mais en tout cas ils
ont attendu ils ont pris leur temps ils
se connaissent à larrieu qu'ils amassent
alors pourquoi laurent fontaine dodeline
est ce que parce que c'est bien raconté
ah oui je vais jusqu'au bout du nez lire
fabriquer de la télé depuis 30 ans
excuse moi mais l'histoire d'avant ils
sont pas approchés depuis quelques mois
je n'avais rien passé chaque famille a
dit déborah mot à dire sur le sujet bah
non mais enfin écoutez
l'espace s'est passé pas ça mais qu'est
ce que vous en avez
dit
il avait pris depuis loi parce qu'on
s'appelle de la diffamation sur
quelqu'un laisse entendre finalement
laurent qui dodelinent j'ai pas dit ça
il dodeline que finalement si tous les
biens déjà beaucoup mandarine pour le
tabac oui eh ben on en dira pas parfois
confettis
sophie davant s'est souvent plainte avec
avec humour souvent mais s'est souvent
plaint de son célibat toujours des
années agassi frais de saïda et lui
n'étaient pas toujours avec les gens
présents depuis plusieurs années à faire
conclut donc à force de vendre des
antiquités elle en a acheté une
moi je vais vous dire ni aucune avis sur
sa vie d'avant j'ai croisé à deauville
quand je vais à deauville m x vous
content là ils font beaucoup il faut un
très beau coup elle est charmante elle a
l'air heureux après je devine pas ce que
j'en sais rien elle n'a pas une très
très bonne réponse pour travailler à la
télé ouais moi je suis dit si tu manques
je suis derrière et c'est des bruits de
couloir ouais elle a pas très très bonne
réputation dans le travail bah williams
non plus haut c'est pas quelqu'un de
très sympa quoi ouais bah ça soir
william non plus ça va c'est pas les
piocher ça où qu'ils soient réunis non
plus quand même on marche sur des oeufs
la whey c'est aussi en dégageant brasse
sophie parce que
je suis encore de ces histoires de
d'autres villages